a esta recta numérica que está dividida
en décimas aquí hay tres décimas podemos
pensar en ella como una multiplicación
de decimales que representa esto les
daré una pista representa algo
multiplicado por tres décimas pausa en
el vídeo y piensen en ello veamos
pasamos una vez tres décimas dos veces
tres décimas tres veces tres décimas y
cuatro veces tres décimas lo que está
representado aquí es cuatro veces tres
décimas a que va a ser igual esto
podemos ver que pasamos de tres décimas
a seis décimas a nueve décimas y podemos
ver esto como doce décimas pero doce
décimas también es igual a un entero y
dos décimas así que podemos verlo como
1.2 un entero y dos décimas hagamos otro
ejemplo aunque mejor lo hacemos sobre la
misma recta numérica queremos
representar 3 por 0.2 como se verá esto
en la recta numérica a que será igual
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
pensemos en que son dos décimas una
décima dos décimas está justo aquí 0.2 y
vamos a multiplicarlo por tres lo
multiplicamos por 1 lo multiplicamos por
2 que nos da 4 décimas y lo
multiplicamos por 3 lo que nos da seis
décimas 0.6 y también podemos visualizar
dos décimas como parte de un entero por
ejemplo esto representa dos décimas
tengo este entero el cuadrado es el
entero que está dividido en diez
columnas iguales de las cuales dos
columnas ya están resaltadas esto
representa dos décimas si tenemos tres
veces dos décimas esto es una vez dos
décimas esto es dos veces dos décimas y
esto es tres veces dos décimas cuantas
décimas ahí hay una dos tres cuatro
cinco y seis que es exactamente lo que
tenemos aquí seis décimas hagamos otro
ejemplo un poquito más complejo aquí nos
dicen mucho
puedes usar los modelos mostrados para
ayudarte a encontrar el producto esta es
una copia de pantalla de un ejercicio de
khan academy así que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo muy bien nos piden
52 centésimas por 3 aquí están
representadas 52 centésimas y están
representadas 3 veces el número total de
centésimas representadas aquí son 52
centésimas por tres aquí hay 52
centésimas
aquí hay otras 52 centésimas y acá hay
otras 52 centésimas cuantas centésimas
serán podemos verlo como 52 por 3 y nos
dará la cantidad de centésimas que
queremos pensemos en esto si
multiplicamos 52 por 3 va a ser 2 por 3
es igual a 6 y 5 decenas por 3 son 15
decenas lo que podemos escribir como una
centena y 5 decenas pero de cualquier
forma si tengo 52 de algo y lo
multiplicó por 3
156 de ese algo y aquí en algo son
centésimas así que si digo que aquí hay
52 centésimas multiplicadas por 3 vamos
a tener 156 centésimas y como
representamos 156 centésimas
hay un par de formas en las que podemos
pensar en esto si esta es la posición de
las unidades esta es la posición de las
décimas y está la posición de las
centésimas escribimos aquí el 6 el 5
aquí y el 1 acá pueden reconocer esto
como 100 centésimas vamos a ponerle un
color 100 centésimas es lo mismo que un
entero y 50 centésimas es lo mismo que
cinco décimas y por supuesto seis
centésimas es igual a seis centésimas
por lo que esto va a ser igual a 1.56
que podemos ver como 156 centésimas que
también podemos ver como un entero pues
son 100 centésimas cinco décimas que son
50 centésimas
seis centésimas